a midwinter's tail is an intriguing
standalone solstice story that also
offers a sneak peek at what we can look
forward to in season 2 of chilling
Adventures of Sabrina spoilers ahead
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
in this video I'm breaking down the 7
biggest season 2 reveals from amid
Winter's Tale and explaining what those
three demon kings are really up to in
Greendale let's begin with Leticia which
we learn is the name that Zelda has
given to the baby girl that she stole
away from far the Blackwood at the end
the holiday episode Zelda explains that
after what happened with kryla she feels
it won't be possible to keep the baby
girl hidden from black wood in the
spellman house so her plan is to take
Leticia to Dez Mulder who she says will
raise her in seclusion teaching her the
old ways as is her birthright Dez Melda
previously appeared in the feast of
feasts episode of season 1 she's an
excommunicated witch who lives alone in
the woods and who's Sabrina and Miss
Ward well and the weird sisters visited
when they were finding out more about
the history of the feast of feasts des
mal de actually has her own history with
a high priest of the Church of night as
she was selected as a queen for the
cannibalistic feast when she was a child
but she fled for her own safety when she
learned the high priest planned to
violate her as part of an initiation for
the ritual
if des Melda is raising a potential
challenger to the all-male hierarchy
that Blackwood is forming at the Church
of night it adds some interest to this
future plotline as she may use the baby
girl as a means of getting revenge for
her past mistreatment by the church
remember that Leticia is Blackwood's
firstborn and therefore the rightful
heir to lead the church over Judas
however Blackwood thinks that Judas is
his only child after zelda decided to
keep laticious birth a secret from him
as she feared for the baby girl safety
Sabrina's mother Diana made a special
appearance in the holiday episode and
gave us what seemed to be a few
revelations about why she's been stuck
in limbo when Sabrina speaks to her
towards the end of the episode Diana
seems to be saying that she was worried
about whether Sabrina was being taken
care of now that Diana can see that
sabrina has a loving family who watch
over her the implication seems to be
that she may now be able to pass on from
limbo however I suspect we will see more
of Diana even if it's only in flashbacks
I also wonder whether there's a chance
any of her appearances were tricked by
miss wood well it's just a possible
theory but when Diana
first appeared during the seance and
Sabrina asked her about why she was
stuck in limbo the message relayed back
was not safe I don't know if she was
just referring to the spirits of the
Yuletide lads who are invading the
Spellman residence or if she was
alluding to something else the other
suspicious thing is that the proof Donna
offered up to Sabrina that she really
was her mum was just her flight number
which is something that could be easily
known by someone to various who
conspired to cause the plane accident or
at least knew about it something we also
discover is that Diana learned some
spells from her husband Edward which is
how she talks to Brina The Changeling
trick she performed on growler however
Diana warns Sabrina that while she
herself followed Edward down the path of
night she wouldn't recommend that to any
other mortals which has implications for
breena's relationship with Harvey at the
end of a midwinter's tale Harvey gives
back to Sabrina the magic pencil she
gifted him and he asks her never to use
magic on or around him again it's an
uncomfortable moment for the pair so I'm
curious as to how in season two we'll
see the two of them back together again
given what we saw teased in the trail of
a part two and will Sabrina actually
keep her tacit agreement not to use any
magic on Harvey again one thing we do
know that's pretty likely from the way
this episode ends and the teasers from
the season 2 trailer is that we'll be
getting more emphasis on the love
triangle set up between Sabrina and Nick
and Harvey although a mid Winter's Tale
wraps up quite nicely it wouldn't be
chilling Adventures of Sabrina without
the tease of something much more
sinister for season 2 oh and now all we
have to do is get through which epiphany
in one piece without its mother terror
rising from the bowels of Hell the which
is epiphany that Hilde is referring to
is likely the coven's version of the
Christian feast day of the Epiphany
which takes place on the 6th of January
and is also known as three kings day
although Hilda is semi joking it looks
like her fears are being realized as the
episode closes with three demon kings
emerging from the entrance of a
Greendale mine in the traditional story
of Christmas three kings or wise men
traveled to visit Jesus after his birth
bearing gifts of frankincense myrrh and
gold the arrival of these three demonic
looking kings in Greendale could be
related to the recent birth of father
Blackwood son Judas and I wonder
they're bringing gifts from hell or the
devil for the little baby boy apparently
the title for the part to premiere will
be the Epiphany so I imagine we'll find
out then another possibility is that the
three kings arrival is to greet the
birth of an antichrist type figure it
might just be a coincidence but it's
curious that NYX scratch was
conveniently away visiting the unholy
lands during the episode and I've talked
previously about NYX possible darker
side as old Nick and old scratch of both
nicknames for the devil the arrival of
these three kings may also be related to
an interesting scene which appeared in
the trailer for the holiday special but
which never actually made it into the
episode in the trailer there's a shot of
Sabrina's father Edward appearing to
offer up a baby to the Dark Lord and
crucially in the background is what
looks like a nativity scene the type you
might see in some Christian churches
over Christmas time if that is a
nativity scene behind Sabrina do the
three demon kings have something to do
with what's going on in this scene
what's especially interesting is why
this scene was teased in the trailer but
never actually appeared in the episode
was it deleted or is it something that's
going to happen in a future episode of
season 2 for example the premiere
looking a bit more closely at what's
going on I suspect this scene is a
vision or dream that Sabrina's having
because she's wearing a nightie and she
isn't wearing her usual black hair band
and I think it also relates back to that
vision Sabrina had in the very first
episode of the series where she saw her
parents with a baby in the woods and
then she discovered a second baby with
cloven hooves the baby that Edward is
shamed to the Dark Lord is also wrapped
in the same white crocheted fabric from
Sabrina's first vision could this be
another hint to an evil twin for Sabrina
in season 2 if you want to know more
about that then tap the card here for my
other video where I explain why Sabrina
may have an evil twin who she's yet to
meet I'll also add a link below in the
video description and at the end of this
video
fans and Michelle Gomez didn't get an
awful lot of the wicked demon s in the
special episode but we do know that she
still hasn't yet received the promotion
she was hoping for from the Dark Lord
obviously she has plenty of trouble plan
for Sabrina in season 2 and by the end
of this episode in a deliciously wicked
moment who takes a gingerbread version
of Sabrina and bites the head off
hinting at more voodoo havoc in season 2
which we also sought
used in the part two trailer in an
interview with ewo runner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa has also revealed that
although dr. Cerberus didn't show up in
this episode were definitely going to
find out what secrets the bookstore
owner is keeping from Aunt Hilda in part
two I suspect aguirre-sacasa may be
hinting at dr. Cerberus as possible
werewolf form teased in the season 2
trailer remember that in season 1 dr.
Cerberus says that he's the oldest of
three brothers and interestingly in
Greek mythology Cerberus is a
multi-headed dog who keeps watch over
the gates to the underworld now my
question for you is do you think we'll
see more of Sabrina's mum Diana in
season 2 let me know your thoughts and
any other ideas in the comments below
tap left for the Sabrina evil twin
theory or tap right for another Sabrina
video you're sure to LIKE and if you
enjoyed this a SUP and a share are
hugely appreciated congratulations to
the winner of my fantastic beasts
giveaway make sure you contact me so I
can send you the prize thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee gay movie lovers